the movie opens up with the U.S
president announcing to the nation that
his administration is doing everything
possible to ensure that their way of
life continues he assures that the
priority is to ensure the safety of All
American citizens it is then revealed
that a biochemical weapons-related
disaster has wiped out the majority of
humanity and rendered the air
unbreathable due to this the United
States government seems to have hastily
constructed a few makeshift underground
bunkers where some scientists are kept
in cryogenic sleep until and unless the
air is no longer toxic each bunker is
maintained by a couple of workers who
are awakened for two hours every six
months in the next scene we are
introduced to two workers at one such
facility named Bauer and Cartwright
Bauer wakes up from his Slumber and
Glides out of his pod feeling nauseous
being an engineer by profession he
begins to examine some computer displays
before his co-worker Cartwright awakens
following this the two go about their
normal lists of tasks during one wake
cycle they inspect the air quality above
and no that it is still toxic they also
noticed that the workers from other
facilities have already checked in
however the communication between
facilities does not appear to be
feasible Cartwright examines photographs
of his friends and family before Bauer
reminds him that they're all deceased
that's why they call him buzz kill Bauer
Bauer then hands him some data to
examine only to discover that there has
been seismic activity as a result they
go check on one of the other sleepers to
make sure everything is okay in the
midst of this Cartwright looks at a
photograph of his wife Abby and has a
hallucination that she is beside him
this vision of his wife prompts him to
talk to her but Bauer is not pleased
with this distraction Cartwright
believes that the sleepers are still
alive and that they are the future of
humanity he has even developed a formula
to determine how long they should remain
in their sleep based on his calculations
he predicts that they may need to remain
asleep for at least 20 more shifts
however Bauer whines that the two of
them are squandering their lives for the
sake of the sleeper's survival just
before the two hours are up
unfortunately Cartwright's sleeping
chamber catches fire as a result of the
recent seismic activity there was a 0.05
chance of him being awake for this he
screams for Bauer to bring the fire
extinguisher but by the time they manage
to put out the fire the sleeping pod has
been destroyed Bauer also injures his
hand in the process as the stopwatch
reaches zero the lights go out and the
air supply is cut off with the help of a
flashlight Cartwright reads the manual
and learns that there is an emergency
override the two of them frantically
search for the Emergency air supply
valve and eventually managed to locate
it and turn it on as the duo waits for
the Air Supply to kick in they share
personal details about themselves Bauer
admits to having a wife and three
daughters and because one of the
requirements for the job was that he'd
be unmarried he chose to lie shortly
after the power is restored the reserve
Air Supply is turned on and the clock is
reset for another two hours without
further Ado the two proceed to the
storeroom In Search of a spare chamber
sadly they don't find one so they are
forced to look for another storage
facility with the help of the map they
walk to the basement despite the fact
that Cartwright is severely
claustrophobic fortunately their hard
work pays off as they are able to find a
spare chamber which they bring back to
the facility and set up when it's
finished Cartwright suggests that he
should go to sleep first in case there
are any issues however he stalls for a
few moments so Bauer decides to go in
instead just when the Pod activates
Bower hears a leaking sound and realizes
that the air inside is thinning out as
Cartwright goes to check on it Bauer
desperately screams to be let out but
Cartwright doesn't hear him suddenly the
chamber malfunctions and sucks Bauer
down causing him to suffocate he is
about to die a painful death when
Cartwright arrives in the neck of time
and frees him by cutting him loose
however in the process he also destroys
the chamber now that there are no other
spare Chambers in the facility Bauer
insists that they eject a random
sleeping person in order to free up a
chamber Cartwright refuses stating that
they are obligated to look after those
people and keep them alive however Bauer
argues that they should prioritize their
own Survival over others Cartwright
finally gives in and considers using
morphine to euthanize one of the
sleepers but right then he has another
hallucination of Abby who convinces him
that there must be another way seeing
his hesitation Bauer decides to do it
himself but Cartwright stops him saying
that they are not murderers this leads
to a minor physical altercation which
ends after both of them become exhausted
subsequently they examine the blueprints
and discover a code ABC that belongs to
another facility Cartwright believes
that the ABC facility is adjacent to
theirs and may contain spare parts
hearing this Bower warns that reaching
it would necessitate breaking the air
seal potentially releasing toxic air the
duo knows that the mission is a risky
one but it is something that they have
to complete hence with no other options
available Cartwright Don's a hazmat suit
and exits the facility with Bauer
providing guidance over the radio along
the way heart rate encounters a
significant amount of blue dust which
Bauer identifies as an Airborne impurity
the latter also fixes some cameras which
makes navigation easier for him in the
next scene Cartwright finds the entrance
to the sister facility but finds that
the lock is jammed however with some
advice from Bauer he eventually manages
to gain entry inside he shockingly
discovers that the facility has been
inactive for a considerable time and
that everyone there is deceased this
makes Cartwright feel hopeless about his
chances of survival but just then he has
another hallucination of Abby she
motivates him to stay strong and
persevere to the last breath meanwhile
Bauer directs him to an air duct located
about 10 yards away Cartwright is
initially hesitant to enter the Doctor
Who to his claustrophobia but he has no
other option as he makes his way inside
he comes across numerous dead bodies
adding to the difficulty of the
situation the radio signal also begins
to weaken as he proceeds further so
Bauer attempts to boost it up he looks
for a knife and finds it in the toolbox
box rather than where he left it earlier
this raises his suspicion so he decides
to check the video footage and determine
how the knife ended up there after
reviewing the footage he shockingly
discovers that Cartwright was standing
next to him the entire time when he was
close to suffocating in the spare
chamber this indicates that the latter
may have attempted to kill him but
changed his mind at the last minute
meanwhile Cartwright senses that
something is wrong he finally makes his
way to the facility and starts to look
around the ceiling opens onto the
planet's surface and as he looks out he
sees that the city has been demolished
by a nuclear bomb Cartwright assumes
that this must have occurred a long time
ago after this as he is exploring the
area he discovers that the sleeper's
chambers have all been destroyed despite
the computer system reporting all
workers in the facility is alive and
well during previous wake Cycles it
appears to be a deception so as to
maintain their sanity and make them
believe that they are not alone Bauer
who is devastated by the video footage
expresses that the entire system is a
lie and that no one can be trusted
Cartwright also starts to believe that
they might be the only ones who survived
now that he is running low on air he
heads back to their own facility he
reaches the door and initiates the
decontamination process on the other
side of the door he sees Bauer holding
the knife and asks where he found it
Cartwright realizes that Bauer is aware
of the truth so he asks to be let in so
that he can explain however Bower
becomes Furious and points his gun at
Cartwright accusing him of trying to
kill him he also regards Cartwright as a
threat to both him as well as the
sleepers when Bauer refuses to let him
in Cartwright who is running out of air
rushes back to the ABC facility at one
point he is lost as he can't find any
way out at the same time he experiences
another vision of his wife who points
him in the direction of the air ducts
the hell does she know that in the midst
of all this bowerby rates him over the
radio saying that the Betrayal and lies
hurt him the most however Cartwright
simply ignores him and continues on path
leading him back to his own facility he
removes his hazmat suit and tries to
head inside the facility's control room
but Bauer blocks his way with a gun
threatening to shoot him Cartwright
quickly takes cover and tries to reason
with him emphasizing that they might be
the only ones left alive regardless
Bauer continues to pursue Cartwright
through the facility claiming that he
cannot let him go because he's afraid he
will kill him in his sleep eventually
after a prolonged Chase Cartwright
manages to find refuge in a medical Bay
where he obtains some morphine he thinks
of using it to murder his co-worker but
then again he starts having cold feet
while Cartwright is deliberating Abby
appears in front of him and urges him to
kill Bauer or else he will she convinces
him that he must do it in order for them
to be together in the future following
Abby's encouragement Cartwright returns
to the control room carrying a gas
bottle but suddenly Bower appears from
behind and shoots him in the shoulder as
Cartwright lies on the ground bleeding
he shows Bauer a photo and pleads for
Mercy during this he also begins to talk
to Abby but Bauer yells that there is no
one here in a moment of distraction
Cartwright seizes the opportunity and
attacks Bauer causing him to drop his
gun he then runs out of the control room
before any further damage is done
meanwhile Bauer picks up the photograph
walks to the sleeper pods and Finds Its
match after realizing that Cartwright's
wife is in one of the sleepers he
threatens him to come out or else he
will kill Abby the situation becomes
very precarious but Cartwright finally
gains the upper hand by sneaking up on
Bauer and injecting a large dose of
morphine into him Bauer turns around and
points the gun at Cartwright but he soon
holds it down and drops on the floor as
the morphine starts to take control over
his body Bauer accepts his fate and
makes peace with Cartwright he asks his
co-worker to take care of his wife
before passing out forever following
this Cartwright goes inside a sleeping
pod and before entering cry asleep he
talks to himself that he is now the only
one left to keep the place functional in
an epilogue Cartwright wakes up for
another cycle but this time he appears
to have aged by many decades the
sleeper's pods also start to open one by
one as the facility system automatically
wakes them up all of them exit their
Chambers and make their way to the
Earth's surface including Abby the movie
ends as Cartwright approaches his wife
and they share a tearful Embrace finally
reunited after all these years subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching